after nearly two years twitch has
clamped down on crypto casinos which
were driving one of the biggest
viewership trends on the platform
gambling there are likely to be
exceptions of plenty and loopholes big
enough to drive a brinks truck through
but unregulated crypto casinos are done
on twitch and in this case
it looks like the hand of twitch may
have been forced
but does it go far enough
well i don't think it's the beginning of
the end but it may well be the end of
the beginning so let's dive in and see
what this announcement actually means
[Music]
all right guys before we get into this i
just want to let you know that if you or
someone you know is dealing with a
gambling problem and wants help there
are resources available to you near
where you live you can follow the link
in the description to visit the national
council on problem gaming and find out
more let's clear up one thing first
gambling has been on twitch for a while
and this new announcement doesn't
prohibit many of the forms you're
familiar with i repeat this announcement
does not ban gambling entirely as per
twitch's announcement poker fantasy
sports and even sports betting will be
allowed on the platform going forward
but as of october 18th slots roulettes
and dice based games on unlicensed
platforms will be banned okay so having
said all that what is this ban actually
targeting well for the most part the
kind of gambling that's taken over some
of the biggest streamers on the platform
doesn't have anything to do with poker
or fantasy sports what you see huge
streamers like xqc and train wrecks tv
playing are games of pure chance on
unregulated casinos that use
cryptocurrency to skirt rules about
gambling the restrictions in place in
the us aren't designed to regulate
bitcoin transactions right now xqc
started getting heavily into it in early
2021 and train wrecks also took a run at
it in april of that year
and the streams did pretty well the
lucrative sponsorship's kind of making
it a no-brainer to continue doing them
but as things progressed people took
notice that gambling was becoming one of
the most popular things to watch on
twitch
and they started to get upset about that
why for one twitch is a public-facing
website with no real age controls like
sure the terms of you say that if you're
under 18 but at least 13 you need to
have parental supervision to use the
site but i seriously doubt some middle
schooler's dad is gonna sit and watch
xqc play sugar rush with their kid it
just doesn't seem realistic
plus he's got better things to do like i
don't know pretend to be a cat girl
online or something right it's not just
about kids like discovering gambling via
twitch that's not really the argument
that people are making because
obviously at some point they're gonna
discover gambling like they'll just
understand that it's a thing that exists
and okay what's different about this is
that a massive internet personality one
that a child might idolize or adore is
selling the gambling to them
even if there's sometimes some mixed
messaging about everything do not gamble
idiots you understand if you watch the
entire context of all my gambling over
15 months you'll see it as 99.8 [__]
losing you understand do not look at big
wins out of context you understand that
you will literally lose plus it was
pretty clear that the way these streams
work had the potential to create some
bad gambling habits the bets were big so
were the wins but the losses were often
even bigger minimum win by 50 bucks
minimum win by 50
on a 1.2 k bet this guy this game is
needs to be [__] removing that
this is so bad and because of the
sponsorship terms
reid they might not even be gambling
with their own money in many cases
the streamer isn't necessarily being
damaged by those losses
but normal viewers don't have that
option the streams got bigger and so did
the deals with train wrecks tv raking in
quote much more
than a million a month for his
sponsorship now that doesn't mean those
streamers kept all that money because at
least in xqc's case he admitted that he
kind of had a problem would you have as
much fun gambling if you were doing it
off stream than on stream
yeah i i'm the i gamble every day i lost
two million really
i lost 1.85 million
guys don't gamble this thing kept
getting bigger and bigger and it was
clear for the gambling sites that these
sponsorships were worth it for them to
reach tens of thousands of viewers per
stream
but something had to give maybe not an
outright ban necessarily but at least
some kind of regulation but twitch
actually did
basically nothing for that entire period
of time in august 2021 they prohibited
links and referral codes to illegal
gambling sites i'm sure no one will be
able to find that gambling website now
guys great job so despite some early
concern and then rising calls to do
something about all this
twitch was basically useless for nearly
two calendar years while some of the
biggest streamers on their platforms
became billboards for unregulated crypto
casinos those casinos by the way are not
exactly the most ethical entities out
there an investigation from internet
detective coffee zilla last year
revealed that streamers who were signing
up their fans for rubet
would earn a percentage of those fans
losses
if only indirectly it's kind of clever
actually because now instead of being
directly tied to their fans losses they
complete innocent they're still
profiting from their fans but you know
in that indirect economic percentage
sort of way that's right in the case of
some of these affiliates
it was in their best financial interest
for their fans to go and lose as much
money as possible i don't feel like
there's too much value in going over
very specific deals but suffice it to
say that these sites felt that these
extremely expensive sponsorships were
worth it even in situations where there
isn't a clause like the rubet one that i
just mentioned like stake for example
was paying enough that drake felt it was
worth his time to do a gambling stream
so they were definitely willing to shell
out to get airtime with big names on
twitch so what changed why now if twitch
has spent
nearly two years doing nothing basically
about this situation in my view there
are a couple potential reasons why
firstly some of the other biggest
creators on the platform began openly
discussing a potential boycott on stream
devin nash had already quit the platform
to take a stand on gambling and he
pokemane and misskiff floated the idea
in a recent stream and even thought
about targeting the holiday season
specifically to maximize the loss of
profits for twitch
if someone said ms signed this right now
and we're going to not stream for a
whole week i would say
can we do longer i would i would totally
be down
yo
charlie the idea of doing it q4 around
christmas too because that'll hurt the
most
yeah yeah it was because that's when
they need the uh the ads
now there's a lot of other twitch drama
that's led up to this over the past week
but i'm not able to go in depth on that
here we are going to do a different
video about that so keep your eyes
peeled for that we're just doing
gambling today as pointed out by hassan
piker's editor austin ox train actually
donated 50 000 to the accounts of two
twitch employees hanging out in his
stream while he was live getting that
third one joe i got you on your 50 stone
trip
don't worry about it baby
remember i'll take your youtube orange
for a minute i got you
the pega fish are you kidding me bro
realm is is that you on two staff
accounts bro the pagan fish comes in i
give them 50k leaves
you can even stay for five more minutes
jesus christ
oh he said no one's ever sent him
anything before
ah
no shot
i love that again this happened live on
stream and later it was confirmed by
zack bussey that neither of these
employees worked at twitch any longer
and hadn't for weeks
while i haven't seen hard confirmation
there was also a tweet dated september
8th that said that former twitch
employee papagafish one of the two
people in that clip had passed away so
exactly who train paid in that previous
clip isn't totally clear i think it's
important to note that train did pay
these people and even if it wasn't an
intentional attempt to curry favor with
twitch something that it seems like
these two people aren't able to do now
anyways
the whole thing looks pretty bad even if
they don't work for twitch any longer
it's possible that these payments are
for services rendered in the past or at
least that appearance could exist and
maybe they're courageous now that they
don't work for twitch so they can simply
accept these gifts for whatever reason
on street
either way
not looking too good again to clarify we
don't have specific evidence that points
to corruption in this exact case but i
do want to point out that it creates a
pretty bad appearance and i think that's
something twitch would like to avoid
honestly that's probably why twitch
finally decided to act and i think
that's one thing that most people will
have no problem agreeing with astanox
about they just didn't care until it
became a huge optics issue now that it
is they're forced to deal with it it's a
tale as old as time the optics issues
don't matter until they get too big
then you deal with them because you have
no choice anymore you can't keep
ignoring it and funnily enough even
twitch's statement kind of
unintentionally draws attention to that
quote gambling content has been a big
topic of discussion in the community end
quote yeah that's true
how long was that by the way and why are
we only getting action now that twitch
employees former or current are having a
year's worth of salary and crypto
donated to them live on stream while
some of your biggest names are openly
plotting revolt from my perspective
there have been calls to do something
about this for over a year twitch seemed
to not care until it became their
problem and now they're finally doing
something like i said at the beginning
of the video the language in twitch's
statement doesn't actually ban slots
roulettes or dice games in their
entirety just on sites that aren't
licensed in the us or other
jurisdictions that provide sufficient
consumer protection but it seems like
the negativity the threats of boycott
and even just the general stigma around
the situation has to force twitch's hand
here
even if it was a profitable situation
with that in mind even this initial
limited step is a big victory for the
streamers and content creators that took
a stand and tried to hold twitch
accountable and until we see those full
rules in october
at least it's the first step
[Music]
you